mais d'abord la vaccination enfin
ouverte à tous les adultes 40% des
tourangeaux et loir et chérien pour
l'instant reçu une première dose de
vaccin contre le coc u19 et ça s'est
donc accéléré aujourd'hui la proche de
l'été d'ailleurs les jeunes ont répondu
présent
voyez ce reportage au centre de
vaccination de saint-avertin avec paul
boyer depuis ce matin la vaccination est
ouverte à tous les adultes sur la
plateforme dr ibn nous avons cochet plus
de 18 ans afin d'obtenir un rendez-vous
bingo direction saint-avertin sur place
les patients ont en moyenne entre 18 et
50 ans au gymnase des onze arpents 1300
injection de pfizer biotech sont
réalisés chaque jour du côté de la
jeunesse cette première injection est un
exutoire avec l'espoir de passer un été
plus tranquille on va être un petit peu
limité je pense si on veut ferme est
ressorti comme avant donc je voulais
être tranquille et le faire avant l'été
c'est surtout pour ma famille et puis
vis-à-vis de mon travail mais également
et le pass and i ter également suivant
les activités qu'on va faire cet été
beaucoup de jeunes moi mais je suis pas
la seule je sais que j'ai des amis c'est
pareil on voulait tous directement se
faire vacciner déjà bas pour protéger
nos familles et on sait que pour
retrouver un monde
normale entre guillemets on va être
obligé de passer par là fini les
critères d'âge ou de santé l'objectif du
gouvernement est d'atteindre les 30
millions de primo vacciner d'ici au 15
juin
depuis une petite semaine on a des
patients beaucoup plus jeune et l'autre
l'autre critère qui m'a interpellé c'est
que on a beaucoup d'antécédents de co
vide qu'on avait beaucoup moins sur des
populations plus âgées pour le coup en
revanche pour le superviseur du centre
certaines populations ne doivent pas
être oubliés maintenant qu'on a des
capacités des deux suffisante du coup on
élargit cependant il faut pas oublier
certaines populations certaines
personnes âgées qui sont pas encore fait
vacciner
et puis les populations précaires vers
qui va falloir aller dans les quartiers
prioritaires de ville ou ailleurs pour
les amener vers la vaccination il faut
que personne ne soit laissé sur le bas
côté de la route
s'occuper des plus jeunes tout en
n'oubliant pas les anciens afin de
revenir à la normale d'ici quelques mois
la haute autorité de santé devrait dire
en milieu de semaine si le vaccin fader
bio intech peut être administré aux
adolescents en france